all right we got an excellent crowd out
here tonight thanks everybody for for
coming to join us and today was supposed
to be a very special leap day edition of
chess openings explained we've been
working on a rug they're working we got
it in the factory it's coming soon we
were going to do something silly tonight
but I just it didn't work out so it's
going to take us about a month for you
know four weeks for about four minutes a
comedy but it's going to be worth it so
the rock is coming back soon so if you
want to send in your requests we're
looking for some nonsense openings this
time so you got something really dubious
probably loses by force that's the kind
of opening that we're going to put in
the box and we're gonna have a silly
episode coming up because for some
reason people don't want to see good
openings but uh okay but there was
somebody they requested a good opening
this week and it's it's something that
I've seen a lot of a lot of people have
made this request so we're going to go
over the Grune failed defense especially
from white's point of view tonight and
the last person to request this was the
dark crazy cyborg so for you uh here it
is this is the green filled okay the
game begins with d4 Knight f6 c4 g6
and okay there's more than one move here
but Knight to c3 is the most principled
the point is we're just going to play E
for next move if they allow it so here's
the the big choice black gets to make is
he going to play Bishop to g7
is it going to be a King's Indian or is
he going to play the move we're going to
look at tonight d5 and this is the
grünfeld defense it's a it's a very
interesting opening it's very sharp it's
highly theoretical and there's lots of
complications and there's all sorts of
lines that white can pick so there's
perfectly good moves here Knight f3 is
good Bishop f4 Bishop g5 all of these
moves make a lot of sense but I think
the most principled way is to play the
exchanged variation which is what we're
going to look at tonight and as the name
indicates it involves in exchange on d5
and why this is so logical is because
when you have a
chance to trade a side pond for a
central pawn and they have to take back
with a piece rather than a pond
generally it's a good positional idea to
make this exchange and black will take
back and now white gets a chance to get
a really big center Bishop to d2 is also
a move here it used to be kind of a
sideline but it's it's really gaining in
popularity but tonight we'll be looking
at the most logical move which is just e
for establishing the big pond Center and
black really should trade here it
doesn't make much sense to go to b6 or
move the knight back to f6 because he's
going to have a lot less space black in
this opening is giving up space in the
hopes that he can create a lot of
pressure in the center so when you have
less space you want to trade a piece or
two so here black should trade and now
we get sort of the the very starting
position for this opening so you'll
notice the big obvious Trump for white
is this huge pond center which controls
a whole lot of squares you'll notice
blacks going to have a hard time putting
anything on the fifth-ranked White has
tons of control but what is black going
to get well he's going to get a lot of
dynamic pressure and the big focal point
for him is going to be the d4 square so
he can play moves like Bishop to g6 c5
Knight c6 and you'll see he's starting
to really ramp up the pressure on white
center so white over the next few moves
he's just going to try to consolidate
keep his Center and blacks going to try
to undermine it and try to get some
counter play going and there's a
interesting move that I like to play in
this position and sorry I have to in
this in this position here and that's
Bishop to c4 which is the move that
we're going to be talking about tonight
but you might be thinking well why not
Knight to f3 certainly this looks like
the most logical move you could make you
put the knight on the best square it's
defending d4 and you might be surprised
to learn that this move actually was not
considered very highly it was thought to
be a mistake a while back but uh in more
modern times they've kind of found ways
to make this move work and the reason it
wasn't so highly thought of is because
I can play Bishop to g4 and exchange one
of the defenders of the d4 square for
example if I white plays a little too
casually black gets to attack the center
and we'll just we'll play you know just
a little bit casually here and we'll
keep defending and ultimately what's
going to happen is he's going to take
your knight which is one of your
defenders of d4 which means here you
already have a kind of a conundrum so
you know that your Knights about to fall
and if that pulls then d4 is going to
fall in this position so you'd have to
play a move like 'if I've which
positionally you really don't want to do
here you're giving up a lot of the light
squares all around the center which
he'll be able to use for some of his
pieces so you want to be able to keep
your pawns on d4 and e4 at least for the
time being until you've castled and you
can play f4 and you can do a big storm
on the kingside so you know if you play
a little bit too casually here you might
have to take on a really bad position
but people have over the over the years
they figured out how to play this and so
one of the main lines in a modern way to
play this position is the move rook to
b1 so rook to b1 puts pressure on the b7
pawn making it harder for you to move
your bishop away because then your pawn
would fall though it is often involving
a sacrifice because at some point black
can take on d5 and then play the move
Queen to a5 attacking your king and the
pawn on a2 so this line often involves
the sacrifice and we'll just show a
brief example of how this might happen
we can see in this position so black has
taken the a to pawn and this is a very
common theme very often black will try
to grab it usually with the Queen but
there's some lines where you can grab
the pond with a bishop you know
sometimes this bishop goes here and then
it goes and grabs the a to pawn and then
white gets an initiative for the pawn
and usually these are very critical
lines and we'll just go a couple more
moves here and you can see in a position
like this White has the center he has
all of his pieces out black hasn't
touched his Queen side pieces yet but he
is up upon will
blackmail to consolidate and ever make
use of his a majority over here he's got
two on zero so this R is probably the
most common way now it's it's a very
testing way to play so if you're playing
this with black you really better know
that line but today I'm going to be
focusing on Bishop to c4 this is how
I've always approached this position and
I think the fact that this is now kind
of become the older line kind of makes
it worth learning now because people
might not know it they're focusing on
the pawn sack lines and you know what
was used to be old is now new again
because people aren't playing it so it
gives you an advantage if you play it
and that they don't know what they're
doing but it's still a very critical
line so I think most black players that
are prepared in this line will have a
good understanding of this move so will
will check it out and the key point is
now the knight is not going to go to f3
the knight is going to go to e to where
if you ever play Bishop to g4 we can
play f3 and kick your Bishop away so
that's what we'll focus on now there's
two moves here using Castle which will
likely transpose to the game we're going
to check out today or you can play the
moved c5 which is the most flexible that
you have a an extra option here with
black that will check out rather than if
you just castled immediately so white's
point was he was going to put his night
on e2 and it's important to keep count
of how many times your d4 pawn is
attacked so you'll notice in this
position it's attacked three times and
it's defended three times so castling
would again transpose to what we're
going to see in just a second but i want
to point out one variation that can
occur if he avoids castling for a while
so he attacks it again so you need to
defend it again and it's funny I was
teaching a kid and he was having a hard
time understanding sometimes things are
attacked once sometimes they're attacked
twice so I showed him this possession
and I had him count how many times is
the d4 pawn attacked and it was really
tough for him you know he's about five
or six it was really hard to see because
it's attacked a lot of times so you have
to be good at math and good at counting
to be able to play this variation so it
is attacked four times which is not
something you see in a lot of openings
and it's only
three times so we need to defend it
again all right now castling again would
lead us to the positions we're going to
look at tonight but there is one
additional option that a black can play
here and that is Queen to a5 before
white has been castled so now you're in
check and you got to figure out how
you're going to get out of this and the
main line is Queen d2 followed or sorry
it's a bishop d2 will look at Queen d2
in just a second Bishop d2 attacking the
Queen and several games go like this and
then you do this and then you do this
and then you make a draw so there's
quite a lot of games when high rated
players they want to make a draw and
they're not in a fighting mood okay this
is one really easy way to try to make a
draw so if you are playing this way as
white you might need to make a
concession if you want to keep playing
here for a win which is one reason why
some people might be turned off of
playing this variation as white if a
draw is fine with you then this is a
perfectly acceptable way to play but
we'll see and I think there is some some
interesting ways to try to get out of
here one move is Queen to d2 that's
probably not the most testing way to try
to fight for a win because the resulting
endgame after black trades is you're
relatively equal for example black will
castle planning to put a rook on the D
file so you can protect in time and
backup and what probably has a very very
slight advantage here in this endgame
but it's not a whole lot you do have the
center you have you know relatively
nicely placed pieces black will continue
with his is normal plan of development
in these positions which is a to reroute
some of his pieces to the c-4 square
which we'll be seeing a whole lot of
today
so this probably isn't the greatest way
to play for an advantage so what what
other ways are possible here let's see
this
back up all the way so that it gets it
all right so there is a different way
that white can play for for a more
complicated game in this position so
instead of repeating by putting the
bishop back on III the game between
Kramnik and Svidler from 1998 saw a
different move d5 and this is uh okay
this is quite an anti positional move
but it's a very tricky one
and both players went you know it's not
a very common way so I think that's also
it's a good move to look at this is a
great game to study if I you're trying
to avoid the draw here because it's it's
not a move white really wants to play
you know we are giving up some dark
squares so the pieces will get to go
there but there are some tricky ways
that we can continue so the bishop is
attacked but White's tactical point here
is Bishop to c3 and all right so you you
can't take my bishop because I'll take
your bishop on g7 attacking your rook
so black cannot can castle defend his
bishop
now the bishop is is really hanging on
c4 so we can back it up and white intend
soon just to play the move f4 and start
rolling his centre forward in this game
this wheeler decided to play Queen to b6
and so we see this move and black got to
threaten checkmate or at least a really
big check okay so what should be done
white should probably stop that
so Bishop to d4 was played and in these
lines usually this is a one of Black's
greatest pieces so it is a piece that he
does want to hang on to for as long as
possible because it is on an excellent
diagonal so whenever what gets the
chance to exchange this Bishop it's
usually in his best interest and here
spyler decided to go into an endgame
though we will see in this endgame you
know the White King is in the center
will black be able to put enough
pressure on the center open up some
files and start attacking the King well
that's not what happened in the game and
after the move e5 trying to preserve the
bishop on g7 Kramnik played a really
excellent move here so this move I
really like most people I think would
either you know
take on e5 or move their Bishop but uh
the move h3 was played so a very nice
move after the Bishop was traded
eventually the g4 pawn is going to fall
and will White's pawns eventually march
up the board and that's what happened in
the game g5 is an interesting attempt so
if this pawn does move either forward or
taking the pond you're given up the e5
square so this was protected and this
isn't the focus of the day so we'll
we'll get to the good parts here and so
he got his uh eventually what happened
was these pawns began to roll and now
black is actually completely lost now in
this position the pawns are just too
strong and in this position you can
pause your video if you want to find it
there's a nice little tactical move that
was played here Bishop takes h7 if you
take the bishop then d7 followed by
queening will win the game so uh black
gave it up here and it's a bit unfair to
do a grünfeld lecture and the only game
was fiddler we show us him losing
because he's a if you are playing this
as black he should be your guide he is
very well known for playing this opening
and always won a lot quite a lot of very
nice victories but uh in a bit of an
injustice we will show only one game
that he lost okay whoa back up we'll get
back to our our main line here so in the
game we didn't see the Knight to c6
followed by trading on d4 both sides
castled all right so black will continue
putting pressure on the center and it
will be a white job to defend all right
and now there's a another big parting of
the ways so we'll give you a second just
to a refresh yourself on this position
and the main move here is Bishop to g4
so that's what we're going to be looking
at today also possible is Queen to c7 so
this is also been played a lot don't my
experience I've had this position
several times in a tournament game so if
you play in the st. Louis area and
pretty sure your opponent's can play
Bishop to g4 because that's what I
always face in this position but Queen
to c7 is possible one of the benefits is
now you're going to put a rook on the D
file so you know the fact that you'll
have a rock on the same file as a queen
that might be quite useful and your
queen is on the same file here as the
bishop so you are threatening to get all
those pieces out of the way you can
start taking and then the knight can
take back and you'll expose an attack on
the bishop so white must be really
careful here and in general this rook
he's either going to a1 or c1 in these
these lines here so rook c1 makes a lot
of sense now if there's a trade on d4
the bishop will be protected all right
so this was the point and there's more
than one way white can play here you can
just play Queen d2 and rook to d1 that's
a perfectly acceptable way to play the
most common way is actually to play
Bishop to f4 where black has tried a
couple different things you can play e5
you can even play Bishop to e5 and
Fiddler's won a good game in this
variation as black so if Fiddler's use
this move even though it's not a very
popular it is worth looking at if you're
you're interested but also possible is
Queen to d7 attacking d4 an innumerable
amount of times so he's attacking that
pawn with everything so yeah you need a
whole hand to count how many times D
four is attacked which means white is
going to be forced to make a concession
in the center and after some position
like this you'll get an endgame where
blacks plan is to play b5 c4 and
maneuver his a knight back around to
look into some of these like squares
over here so a very interesting way to
play but today we're going to focus on
the main move here which is Bishop to g4
so he is hoping to provoke f3 so okay
and now you might be thinking you know
what are you going to do with this
Bishop there's not really a great place
to retreat the bishop I mean you can go
back to e6 and accept doubled pawns
Bishop d7 is probably okay you probably
don't want to go all the way back but
blacks intention here is to tactically
use his next move to to continue playing
to move this Bishop out of the way
so Knight to a5 here is the the main
move and again white has two moves here
so normally when you have a threat and
your opponent has a threat the best
response is just to you know move your
bishop out of the way which is why we're
going to look at the main move Bishop to
d3 because now your opponent has to
respond to your threat so he'll have to
move this Bishop out of the way and then
it will be your turn to do something and
use your initiative it is possible to
win upon here so perhaps you're thinking
tactically can't I just take this pawn
and then take this bishop so you want a
pond but this is not thought to be the
most testing variation it's not thought
very highly of because that black does
end up getting a lot of activity though
it is a playable line so you can
consider playing this way black will
normally consider taking here and you
you basically have to take back with the
King if you take back with the Queen you
can get into a little bit of trouble
with a move like Knight to c4 so we see
the knight coming to c4 that's one of
the squares he's always looking at in
this variation and either your queen has
to defend your dark squared Bishop or
otherwise you know and let black take it
or you can play here and blunder your
epod goes after a move like this this is
not why you you tried to win upon here
just to let him win it back and get a
very nice position here so so you need
to take back with a king that's
important to remember here and there's
more than one way black can play but the
most common is trading in playing the
move e5 so you don't have to push here
but okay pushing is possible and just to
show you an example of how black can get
very active pieces in this line we'll
look at our Queen to see for attacking
the bishop followed by piling up on the
F file and as you can see black does get
quite a lot of pressure and you know all
you get you get this extra G pawn which
might be useful in the future but it's
kind of known that this line is a is
very nice for black it is kind of even
so you can play this way but more common
if we back all the way up is not to take
it on f7
this is the play Bishop to d3 okay now
that the bishops moved he can trade and
play Bishop to e6 now we'll see that
he's got two pieces looking here at c4
and the problem for white now is the
only way he can take control over c4 in
any reasonable way is to sacrifice some
material so we're going to be looking at
the main move which is d5 which
obviously sacrifices the exchange on a1
but to try to understand that let's look
at what if what if we instead try to
control c4 with our rook obviously this
is a a pawn sacrifice and black should
probably be willing to take it and the
seed is what going to be able to get
enough for the pond that he's sacrificed
for example Queen to a4 and he does
eventually get the move d5 in okay so we
reach a position like this black is a
pawn up he does have you know a decent
Center in some nice pieces but black has
a good way of playing here there's
there's two ways probably the best is
ad604 in your knight back to one of
these dark squares y can actually meet
this with Bishop to a6 preventing Knight
to b7 and preventing you from ever you
know putting a rook here but he doesn't
need to play this way ecigs
gives black a very nice game after this
sample continuation not don't eat one
but okay a position like this black is
up upon and it's not so obvious that
white has complete compensation for it
so this is not the the way that they
normally play and you may be thinking if
we we back up to this position so if
instead of rook to c1 what if instead we
play Queen to a4 with the idea that now
we're going to play Rick to c1 in our
pawn is already protected but this line
is even worse than the last one because
black has the strong move a six the idea
is to play b5 getting even more control
over c4 so now if you play rook to c1
you're in bad shape after b5 because if
you try to you know stay connected to
your a pawn here Knight to c4 is a very
annoying move and if you have to take
this you're still in a little bit of
trouble now your knight is under attack
and if you defend it black can win upon
here by taking your knight and then
taking on d4 so notice even if you play
a move like work to d2 attacking a
pinned piece he can always take on e3
with check to get himself out of trouble
so here black is just truly up upon and
white doesn't have any compensation so
that's why when you do reach this
position people play the move d5 okay so
black should probably grab this material
and okay white should take back and now
again it's a there's some little bit of
tactics going on white is not really
thinking of taking this bishop yet so
black can leave it hanging there because
the bishop on d3 would be exposed if you
played D take c6
so the most common move here is that to
start defending the dark squares to
guard against you know these these
possible threats here with a move like
f6 okay and now we're going to be
looking at the game to Paul off sheer
off from Linares in a 2008 and that game
saw something that was not the main line
but I think it's a it's a very nice way
to play and that's just with Bishop to
d4 defending your bishops
so you are threatening to take on e6 but
the main line which is a very exciting
line is a Bishop to h6 threatening to
you know just win back the exchange so
black normally moves it and we'll get a
good glimpse here of how crazy some of
these lines can be but the reason people
don't play these lines as much is
because it's all been worked out to a
draw well that's a very complicated and
crazy draw now in a lot of lines black
is thinking about you know
playing Queen b6 so why can't play a
move like Bishop to b5 here because he
would lose a piece so normally he gets
off of that diagonal and okay so now Lac
is thinking I'm going to put something
on c4 and now the knight comes in so
this is starting to look a little bit
dangerous so some people like to play
this way is black you're up in exchange
but a lot of attackers are coming near
your King here so what's going to happen
so the bishop is attacked and it will
normally go to d7 and the reason is okay
we might in the future maneuver the
bishop to c2 to try to trade for one of
White's attacking pieces here and now
white plays a 5 so if you're not
prepared this is this is pretty scary
all of White's pieces here are doing a
great job so these are all pretty scary
pieces to have near your King and it's
not so easy to put any defenders
directly by your king so what's going to
happen well that comes into c4 attacking
the e pawn ecigs all right and so he's
getting ready to you know play moves
like Knight to e5 and Bishop to c2 and
white here can go all in for the attack
he can sacrifice on g6 so this is scary
you know if you if you don't know this
position you see these bishops right by
your king it's a pretty nerve-racking so
you do need to have sort of nerves of
steel if you're going to play this way
as black because you're really playing
with fire if black doesn't play
accurately enough he could very easily
find himself checkmated and he has to
play very very precisely in order to
make a draw here but uh okay Knight to
e5 white better not think about just
grabbing the exchange here because you
are down material so that won't help you
any so he's got a you know keep his his
Bishop alive so tacking continue but now
this ship to c2 and after this trade
Queens ad1 and if white were gifted just
one more move if he could play the move
f4 here he would have a totally winning
position but black is just in time here
with one of either two moves Queen to c7
is a playable move here but a king to h7
has also been worked out to a draw for
example taking on on c2 leads to a draw
as does f4 it will look at one line here
she'll notice there's there's several
lines that could play here and it looks
very very scary for black like his King
is super exposed but what actually
doesn't have any way of making progress
here and wait occasionally has to worry
about his own back rank so it's hard for
him to ever move his queen or rook off
of the first rank there and so this is
something that both players should know
very well and this is why you kind of
need to know a lot of theory when you
play these lines because there's there's
a couple of different drawing lines but
this should just be an equal position
here so in in the game that we're
looking at here not the main line but
instead after the exchange so not Bishop
to h6 in this game Queen to d4 okay so
we are threatening your bishop on e6
alright and now what to do okay now
white will in this position harass the
rook a little bit so okay we don't want
to just give back the exchange and it
looks like White's very close to just
getting that that rook but black does
have one saving move here he does have a
way to save his rook and that's the move
e5 which is nice for black in a certain
way one it gives the rook to e7 Square
and it does solidify some of these dark
squares around his King so in that
respect it's really good it doesn't make
any sense here to take on
because the rook will just take and
you've you are just down in exchange so
you do want to keep some stuff on the
board here you don't want to ever be in
a position where you might trade Queens
so the Queen goes back to f2 where it
might make an appearance over on the
Kings side if white ever gets an attack
going and what is interesting about this
game is that these two players played
the year before in 2007 and in that game
white played the only move that had been
played at that time which sorry after
the rook escapes is the move f4 so we'll
look at the game from 2008 where Bishop
to d3 was an improvement and it was a
novelty at the time so removed 20 and
finally there's a novelty so this is a
very theoretical variation but we'll
take just a very brief look at f4 which
is sort of White's main idea he's going
to open the F file so he can get his
Queen and rook going and just to show
briefly what happened in this game they
reached a very equal position some scary
stuff is happening but white eventually
ended up winning this game he found the
really nice maneuver at just the right
time this this Knight came to f6 which
which black allowed and that ultimately
led to his his demise but uh okay so he
decided now in 2008 he was going to play
the move Bishop to d3 which is an
improvement so before he plays f4 he
gets his Bishop out of the way just to
make sure there's no you know Queen to
b6 attacking his bishop in the future
and on his next move now he's going to
play f4 he's going to get a very similar
position and let's check it out alright
so again black takes control over c4
that's this big plan in all of these
lines so the knight c4 is coming soon
and f4 so White's coming through in the
Kings side will black get enough counter
play on the Queen side Knight to c4 and
white decides he's going to open up the
F file okay and ah alright there's three
ways that you can take care the worst
would be with a pawn
because what would black play here last
the audience so it's a simple move does
anyone see whether well white would play
yeah
Bishop D v g5 right yeah so this would
win some material you can take with the
Rooker the knight
they're both relatively equal so he took
with the knight very tricky move you are
attacking the bishop you might be
thinking of going to g4 forking some
pieces but it's white Stern and he gets
to make a threat so he's threatening
checkmate on g7 and somehow black needs
to get the bishop out of the way to stop
that threat so Bishop takes d5 and it's
funny in this position I was showing
this to to a friend of mine and I said
of course black can just bail out with a
check in this position and he couldn't
find the check which I thought was kind
of unusual so who can find a check here
we'll see we'll see how easy we can make
the questions tonight because there's a
decently high rated player that couldn't
find the check here yeah Queen b7 yeah
oh the computer gave it away yeah so
this would be a the check that he could
force the trade of Queens here
very good but of course you're still up
in exchange but the fact that now you're
two-to-one majority over on the Queen
side has kind of been shattered it's not
going to be very easy for either side to
make a lot of progress here but it was a
very possible continuation but instead
Bishop takes d5 alright so I took back
and now ah you kind of got to play
Bishop to g4 but let's blunder for a
minute what happens
if we take this bishop so there's
actually three moves that will win
fairly easily but one is the strongest
so again I ask the audience what would
white play here
how are we yeah here here there they are
here somebody's working it out right and
there's more than one answer here but uh
the strongest move do you know it g6 d6
excellent yeah this is the the strongest
move in the position so good the rooks
attacked and in a position like this
why would be able to check the king and
after rook to f8 you're going to take
all of blacks pieces so this would be a
catastrophe for black here but okay so
wisely the night went to g4 attacking
the Queen and now he's going to be able
to pick up that pesky bishop on h6 which
is really an annoying piece so the Queen
can go anywhere where she protects the
bishop and then this trade was made so
okay now the most obvious move is the
best but I guess black made a
miscalculation here and the obvious move
is just to take this pawn on d5 and so
if black would have found this move it's
very likely the game would have ended in
a draw eventually because I mean this is
just a very playable position for both
sides for example if he does play Knight
f4 we can throw this check in black
could play a move like rook to f7 with a
devious threat the threat is Queen takes
Bishop exploiting the pin and okay so
why should protect the bishop attack the
rook black moves the rook to safety now
he is threatening rook takes f4 why
would have to play a move like g3 and
this position should be relatively equal
here it's hard to see either side
winning
you got two super grand master's plan
but instead after the Queen took back
black decide to play the move Queen to
b6 check so not taking the pawn I assume
in this position this is what he saw in
his head he must have only calculated
trade in Queens which does probably
produce a relatively equal endgame and
the rook should be able to put enough
pressure on the D pawn to eventually win
it and the draw is the most likely
result here but I this is the move he
must have missed White has a very strong
move here to give him a very serious
advantage we going to say something okay
and that move is Queen to h4 just keep
in contact with the rook on e7 so now
you can't take the bishop because you'll
drop your rook and black compounded his
troubles by moving his rook hoping maybe
to take the e pawn hoping maybe to take
the bishop but white continued to find
the best moves here and after Queen to
f6 white is completely winning black is
in a lot of trouble where we've got some
some pretty big threats in the game he
went back to e8 it's worth noting you
might be here okay black really really
wants to trade the Queen's because
things are starting to look scary but
here the continuation would probably
have been like this and a simple move
here is just very very strong again d6
so black had a chance to take that deep
on but in this variation the pawn really
would have got active it's going to go
to d7 soon and it's going to cause a lot
of problems for the second player but
okay so he went all the way back and all
right now a relatively simple tactic
occurred so you may want to pause your
videos it's nothing nothing overly
brilliant but in this position Bishop
takes g6 so getting rid of all the pawns
in front of the black king and now
checkmate is just around the corner here
so the game finished up with its check
and as I always teach my students why
did find the most accurate and best way
to continue this which is very important
it makes the whole game look more
artistic the best move here was played
and now after this if you go up to h6
then my route gets to come in rook to f6
would be played so you have to go back
and after Knight to f4 black resigned
this Knight is just coming in to g6
there's not a whole lot you can do about
it the computer wants you to just sack
your queen for the night
yes you're in a lot of trouble here maid
has come in so in this position he did
indeed just give it up okay so that's
just a little brief introduction into
the the groom fell defense we got our
tournament coming up tonight so it's the
last round of a but we already know
who's going to win the book so he's
sitting here in the audience and a the
tournament coming up this next month is
going to be excellent so in March we're
given away the prize for Monday night
mayhem is going to be an entry into the
bill right st. Louis open so that's one
hundred dollar value the biggest prize
we've offered to date so hopefully
people come out on Monday night's
playing the tournament and you could win
a hundred dollar prize so all right
again we're going to try to get the
wrong back so if you got some suspicious
openings you want to see then we can put
it in a box have a little little fun out
here please let me know keep sending in
your comments like subscribe and thank
you guys for coming